nobody is superior nobody is inferior
but nobody is equal either
people are simply unique incomparable
you are you i am i
love and respect yourself and never
compromise for anything and then you
will be surprised how much growth starts
happening of its own accord
as if rocks have been removed in the
river has started flowing
courage is a love affair with the
unknown
[Music]
to avoid pain they avoid pleasure to
avoid death they avoid life
life begins where fear ends
[Music]
be realistic
plan for a miracle
only laughter makes a man rich but the
laughter has to be blissful
i teach you to be more conscious and
love will come as you become more
conscious
it is a guest that comes that comes
inevitably to those who are ready and
prepared to receive it
[Music]
there is no greater ecstasy than to know
who you are
my meditation is simple it does not
require any complex practices it is
simple it is singing it is dancing it is
sitting silently
beautiful to be alone it is also
beautiful to be in love to be with
people
and they are complementary not
contradictory
love the person but give the person
total freedom love the person but from
the very beginning make it clear that
you are not selling your freedom
don't move the way fear makes you move
move the way love makes you move
move the way joy makes you move
falling in love you remain a child
rising in love you mature
by and by love becomes not a
relationship it becomes a state of your
being
not that you are in love now you are
loved
[Music]
to avoid pain they avoid pleasure to
avoid death they avoid life
become alert relationship destroys love
destroys the very possibility of its
birth
truth is simple very simple so simple
that a child can understand it in fact
so simple that only a child can
understand it
unless you become a child again you will
not be able to understand it
love as a byproduct of meditation
get out of your head and get into your
heart think less feel more
let it all go see what stays
[Music]
a single moment of love is equal to the
whole eternity of love
whatever you feel
you become it is your responsibility
creativity is the greatest rebellion in
existence
drop the idea of becoming someone
because you are already a masterpiece
you cannot be improved you have only to
come to it to know it to realize it
nobody has the power to take two steps
together you can take only one step at a
time
always remember to judge everything by
your inner feeling of bliss
don't be so short of trust and don't be
in a hurry
if i say something wait search and you
will find the way
if you are a parent open doors to
unknown directions to the child so he
can explore
don't make him afraid of the unknown
give him support
they say
think twice before you jump i say
jump first and then think as much as you
want
be a lotus flower be in the water and do
not let the water touch you
a certain darkness is needed to see the
stars
a comfortable convenient life is not a
real life the more comfortable the less
alive
the most comfortable life is in the
grave
discover yourself otherwise you have to
depend on other people's opinions who
don't know themselves
a woman is to be loved not understood
that is the first understanding
respect life revere life there is
nothing more holy than life nothing more
divine than life
it's not a question of learning much on
the contrary it's a question of
unlearning much
[Music]
millions of people are suffering they
want to be loved but they don't know how
to love
and love cannot exist as a monologue
it is a dialogue a very harmonious
dialogue
life is not a problem to look at it as a
problem is to take a wrong step it is a
mystery to be lived loved experienced
there is no need for any competition
with anybody you are yourself and as you
are you are perfectly good
except yourself
there exists no god what exists is
godliness and that godliness surrounds
you we are all in the same ocean
discover yourself otherwise you have to
depend on other people's opinions who
don't know themselves
you need either to create something or
to discover something either bring your
potential to actuality or go inwards to
find yourself but do something with your
freedom
[Music]
the moment a child is born the mother is
also born
she never existed before the woman
existed but the mother never a mother is
something absolutely new
friendship is the purest love it is the
highest form of love where nothing is
asked for no condition where one simply
enjoys giving
truth is not to be found outside no
teacher no scripture can give it to you
it is inside you and if you wish to
attain it seek your own company be with
yourself
[Music]
tomorrow never comes it is always today
[Music]
life is a balance between rest and
movement
[Music]
life in itself has no meaning
life is an opportunity to create meaning
[Music]
be less of a judge and you will be
surprised that when you become a witness
and you don't judge yourself you stop
judging others too
and that makes you more human more
compassionate more understanding
it is a strange thing that every child
is born with a closed hand and everybody
dies with an open hand
[Music]
you